Hello, lover.
♪ (UPLIFTING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
In New York,
they say you're always looking
for a job, a boyfriend,
or an apartment.
I've been dating since I was 15!
I'm exhausted! Where is he?
Who, the White Knight?
CARRIE BRADSHAW:
Sometimes, it's hard to walk
in a single woman's shoes.
That's why we need
really special ones
to make the walk
a little more fun.
Have you ever been in love?
Abso-fucking-lutely.
Why do I think living
in Manhattan is so fantastic?
Because it is.
CHARLOTTE YORK: There's always
a new neighborhood,
-a new restaurant.
-A new man!
Maybe you have to let go
of who you were
to become who you will be.
Are we still gonna have to
call it date night in our 50s?
I'm a try-sexual.
I'll try anything once.
It's all fun and games
'til someone has a child.
CARRIE: If you find someone
to love the you you love,
well, that's just fabulous.
Maybe we could be
each other's soulmates.
(CHEERING)
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
(SCREAMS)
(CHEERING)
CARRIE: The most important thing
in life is your family.
Sometimes it's the family
you're born into,
and sometimes it's the one
you make for yourself.
(EXCITED SHRIEKING)
♪ (MUSIC FADES OUT) ♪
♪ ("SEX AND THE CITY"
THEME PLAYS) ♪